look us what was the seed that got
planted that became this film how did
the idea come about the idea for the
film started in 2009 I was 18 at the
time and I had just finished high school
and I was gonna start film school and I
read an article in a Belgian newspaper
about a young fifteen year old girl that
wanted to become a ballerina but was
assigned male at birth and I had an
immediate admiration for her more
specifically because for me it was
really an example of someone that shows
the truest version of herself at a very
young age and wanted to pursue this
dream this ambition that she had to
become a ballerina I thought there was
so much beauty in that and I contacted
her because I wanted to make a
documentary with her but at that moment
in time she didn't want to be filmed
because she was going through the
medical process and because it was too
vulnerable for her to be on camera so
she does we decided to make something of
it
without her having to be in front of
that camera and so we made a fiction
film that became this film that you just
saw in which the dialogues that we had
during five years were at the base of
this script and actually what what was
the seat for me personally as a director
is that at 18 I was not able to be as
honest as she was because I myself was
not okay yet with my sexuality it took
me three more years so in a way she
wasn't a personal example for me of
choosing honesty and that was my
admiration to her but when I got to know
her when we were really talking I found
out that even though she had been so
honest
early on in her life
about who she was she had now come at a
point that she really wanted to fit in
she wanted to be like the rest all
teenagers do as all teenagers do and
there I really recognized that feeling
and I found what I really wanted to talk
about about that moment in our lives
where we want to fit in rather than
stand out and yet it gave you more
latitude you were lucky in a way that
she didn't want to do the documentary
because you got to tell the story your
way yeah that's true I mean we we got to
shape it we got to craft it we got to
make it actually this is very close to
Norah story story but it's a different
story it's Lara
story and in a way I think what was so
good for me to see is that if I would
have made a documentary of Norah then it
would be a film for me and an audience
but this way having Norah involved in
the fiction of it it also became a tool
for her to let go of a certain moment in
her life because she used the making of
this film as a way to distance herself
from something that had happened in the
past so I'm very proud that this film
was not only something for an audience
and for me but it's also something for
her how closely involved was she in the
making of this mmm um during the writing
she was very involved
she was we had a lot of talks about what
we could do with a script like this
about with a character like this what
she felt like was important to show or
not show and then during the casting I
wanted her advice because of course the
casting for this film was very
challenging but I really wanted her to
agree with the person that was gonna
play Laura and then in the preparation
with Victor they met each other a lot
she came to set a lot and if Victor
describes it he says that he got
confidence by the fact that she stayed
there the fact that she stayed meant for
him that she saw something that was good
and that gave him a lot of comfort this
is the first
time that this person acted 14 when I
met him 15 when we shot this so and he
was very very nervous of not doing her
justice and so the fact that she stayed
on set the fact that she was there gave
him the confidence that he needed to to
play this part
so obviously the the film would rise or
fall on the casting how on earth did you
find Victor
well the casting was the most difficult
process of the production we had been
casting for a year and a half we had
seen over 500 young people of which
trans girls boys and girls and the very
challenging thing for this part was that
you needed to be 15 dance on the level
that you can dance a choreography of
Sydney Leroux Sharkey which is not easy
act carry a feature film and will
present his identity in a way that it is
complex you know that people will be
looking at that and so we didn't find
all those things in one person and that
was very difficult for us and then all
of a sudden we started casting the
secondary roles because we didn't know
how to continue with the main role and
Victor applied for one of the other
dancers in the film and when he came my
whole team we were looking at each other
because we were like wait it's like a
scene from a movie yeah exactly and we
have felt this immediate attraction to
this person by the way he moved by the
way he positioned himself in the group
and you could immediately feel that it
was someone that was very close in a lot
of ways to Nora if you know Nora if you
felt that the similarities and so so
yeah
Belgium is split by language and culture
yeah and you have you reflect that a
little in the cement in the languages
was that important too to get across in
your store
yeah I have in my OMA in all my films
all my short films I have always used an
Flemish and French we live in a country
that is divided by its language barrier
and our industries are divided as well
so we have a Flemish industry and a
French and I just like the idea of
identifying as a Belgian filmmaker
because I like the idea of working
together and I also like the idea that I
can work with people from the and the
French and the Flemish industry but also
it actors from both of them and in this
script in a way it was very handy
because we needed a rupture as the
family moves to another environment we
could also make it in the script a
rupture in language and so for us that
was a way to again integrate and Flemish
and French I think for me and you have
some political parties that want to
separate our country which is a stupid
ID so I think it's important to unify in
those moments please thank Lucas don't